[Musique]
le président du modem martinique est
avec nous le modem partenaires dans
marche alliés du parti présidentiel
bonjour max orville bonjour maurice lieu
le tombeau jour aux auditeurs de
martinique 1ère nous vivons les épisodes
nationaux de ces deux partis qui ont
remporté la présidentielle en mai
dernier mais mais mais ici en martinique
ces deux formations sont plutôt
discrètes vous n'arrivez pas à
transformer l'essai dans notre île pas
de lame de fond max orville mais à
écouter comme vous l'avez dit en marche
est un parti jeune qui émergent le modem
est un petit peu plus anciens mais enfin
ça ne fait quand même pas dix ans que il
est sur la place le modem à quelques
conseillers municipaux et nous allons
aux élections et j'espère bien que l'on
n'arrive pas à cerner il fait pourtant
pour l'instant la vague qu'il y avait eu
lors des élections nationales n'a pas
encore frappé la martinique
ouais pourtant vous semblez vous activez
puisque le parti au plan national le
modem lance une réflexion ce sera dès
mercredi sur nos pays à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une façon d'exister
oui une façon d'exister en tout cas
c'est très important dans le cadre de la
semaine de contrôle du gouvernement le
modem a pris l'initiative de mettre les
outre mer à l'ordre du jour
et d'interroger le gouvernement sous
forme de 23 questions mercredi 21 sur la
politique économique et fiscale
outre-mer qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour nos franchement mac sort il a
écouté qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour
vous je ne sais pas pour vous mais aux
yeux le ton mais pour nous ça veut dire
que pour la première fois ou deux puis
très le fort longtemps un groupe
parlementaire nationale décide
d'accorder une place à l'outre-mer alors
qu'il n'y avait pour l'heure aucun sujet
d'actualité
donc c'est une manière c'est un premier
pas pour mettre un éclairage sur les
outre mer et pouvoir contrôler un homme
d'action il y aura un rapport il y aura
des conclusions qui vont terminer dans
un tiroir vous le savez alors monsieur
maurice vu le temps on va poser la
question à l'envers
ce qu'on ne parle pas de l'outre-mer
vous nous dites que l'outre-mer n'existe
pas lorsque un groupe national contribue
à éclairer un petit peu les lecteurs le
citoyen sur la situation d'outre-mer et
même les députés ultramarins puisque
manifestement tous n'avaient pas cette
possibilité d'être entendu ces assisses
de l'autre maire max orville on se
marche pas sur les pieds
les assises de l'outre-mer est différent
c'est différent je bats la même chose
oui mais le problème c'est que vu de la
population ne s'améliorent pas le
quotidien concrètement ça va aboutir à
croix pour les martiniquais qui nous
écoutent lors ce moment qu'ils sont
coincés dans les embouteillages qui ont
des défaites difficiles eh bien écoutez
déjà ce débat va permettre de connaître
et peut-être d'infléchir la politique
économique et fiscale pour les
ultramarins
deuxièmement de pouvoir poser des
questions au gouvernement sachant que la
ministre a l'intention de poser des
réformes notamment ce qui concerne des
petites et moyennes entreprises donc de
pouvoir peaufiner d'avoir des
explications concernant ces petites et
moyennes entreprises qui sont légion en
outre mer en tout cas deux heures de
débats mercredi après midi en france
avec 23 question d'avoir ce ce à quoi on
va vers congrès avec cette 7e réunion
l'assemblée nationale dans cette même
veine
vous serez dans l'organisation d'une
autre manifestation a cette fois ci il
s'agit d'un colloque caraïbes europe en
avril
mais là encore ce sera de la réunionite
à monsieur viol dont il s'agit d'un
colloque caraïbes europe qui se tiendra
dans nos régions
comme vous l'avait dit en avril mais
c'est une première avec le avaitil
démocrates européens avec le parti
démocrate européen nous allons éviter
donc des parlementaires européens de
tous horizons qui viendront parler des
rup avec les régions ultrapériphériques
ici en martinique ou en guadeloupe pour
pouvoir mieux comprendre les
problématiques sur trois thèmes les rup
justement quel avenir dans les instances
locales dans les instances nationales
dans les instances européennes
comment nous allons pouvoir commercer
avec les pays de la caraïbe 1 dans quel
domaine
sous quelle forme la deuxième question
le deuxième thème qui sera abordé
concernera les tpe
quels financements eu égard aux
dispositions nationales de ces
parlementaires et enfin un troisième
thème changement climatique et
résilience insulaire ce sont donc des
thèmes transversaux ce ne sont pas des
thèmes polémiques ce sont des thèmes qui
nous concerne ici le citoyen le chef
d'entreprise et les élus sur ces trois
thématiques c'est la première fois que
ça arrive là encore venu me dire ça va
changer quoi lancer l'opération des
martiniquais long mais il s'agit par
exemple des élections européennes mais
nous le savons mais nul ne peut ignorer
la porte de l'europe sur nos régions ce
sont indéniablement alors à partir de
convaincre les martiniquais qu'un
journaliste est bien de toute façon
c'est ce que nous allons essayer de
faire c'est de pouvoir à l'issue de ce
colloque avoir une sorte de petit livre
blanc qui résume un petit peu les
propositions et les actes qui auront été
fait et qui pourrait être porté par un
parti européen pléthorique auprès de la
commission je crois que dire que rien ne
se passe
ou bien qu' il ya des négligences vous
forcer le trait j'organise donc j'existe
max orville pour vous écouter si faire
de la politique c'est rester chez soi et
puis s'occuper des concours des uns et
des autres c'est pas mal c'est par
conception
parce que faire dès qu'on craint c'est
ce qui semble caractériser la politique
en martinique
écoutez vous avez par exemple vous en
tant que président du modem sur le
développement économique du pays à
travers notamment cette collectivité
territoriale à travers les communautés
d'agglomération mais écoutez nul ne peut
ignorer et tout le monde voit bien que
la martinique est en peine nul ne peut
ignorer que cet outil qui est la
collectivité territoriales de la
martinique que le modem n'avait pas
appelé de ses voeux ne remplit pas
toutes ses missions et toutes ces
fonctions vous le savez en tant que
journaliste averti
nous avons vécu ces dernières semaines
des crises dans la majorité
en martinique et des gens qui
s'interpellent qui s'invectivent bien et
donc on constate qu'il y a effectivement
des dissonances au sein de cette
majorité
on parle beaucoup de la cité mais les
communautés d'agglomération les
présidents les trois présidents de
l'espace sud de la cacem de cap nord qui
sont relativement discret ambiante en
pas beaucoup je veux croire qu'elle
travaille je venais de la ba écoute et
je veux croire qu'ils travaillent ils
font de toute façon ce qu'ils peuvent et
dans un contexte qui est
particulièrement difficile sur le plan
économique sur le plan social et il n'y
a pas malheureusement le projet la
vision qu aurait dû porter peut-être la
ctm qui à la tête de tout
de tout ce mouvement j'en veux dire
politique
eh bien il n'y a pas une unité de vues
donc chacun fait un petit peu ce qu'il
peut chez soi ce que nous aurions voulu
c'est beaucoup plus de cohérence
beaucoup plus d'harmonie beaucoup plus
d'unité et ce n'est pas là votre combat
max orville c'est bien de parler de
cette réunion de mercredi prochain c'est
bien de parler de ce colloque au mois
d'avril mai prochain mais ce que le
modem ne doit pas peser auprès de ses
instances auprès des dirigeants
politiques auprès des formations auprès
de toutes les collectivités pour que le
devenir des martiniquais familia et bien
écoutez est-ce que vous en avez les
moyens nous avons les moyens sur le plan
national puisque nous faisons partie de
la majorité et donc nous faisons ici
modestement remonter un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements mais encore une
fois la question européenne et centrale
peut-être pas aux yeux des martiniquais
mais aux yeux des politiques parce que
c'est l'europe qui nous financent un
certain nombre de projets et un certain
nombre d'actions
donc été très chaotique la gestion des
fonds européens mais pas envie de
prendre bâton de pèlerin en tant que
chef de parti pour aller dire aux
instances dirigeantes
les gars en rouge et renom pour
l'instant nous allons les réunir au sein
de ce colloque les invitations seront
faites
il y aura des invitations également
comme jeudi auprès des responsables
gouvernementaux de la caraïbe étrangers
qui vont venir nous justement les trois
thèmes que nous posons ce sont des
thèmes transversaux des thèmes or
polémique mais des thèmes qui
intéressent non c'est franchement
concurrents la gestion des fonds
européens sont eux se soient polémique
ce tout dépend de l'utilisation et la
manière dont c'est fait mais du jeu ne
le modem ne va pas aborder ça sous cette
forme
seul le modem va essayer d'aborder
toutes ces thématiques de manière
constructive avec tout le monde tout le
monde autour d'une table quels sont les
problèmes quelles sont les difficultés
que ces 100 jours de grève la réunionite
en prenant mais non mes côtés une fois
qu'on a identifié m'y essayer de mettre
tout le monde autour d'une table pour
essayer de régler un certain nombre de
difficultés structurelles que nous avons
après qu'est ce qui se passe aussi c'est
que dans le contexte autonomistes
indépendantistes
est ce que la question des relais se
pose
sur le plan national le modem a les
moyens et le fait savoir
de pouvoir non plus dire nous allons
parler à bruxelles nous allons nous en
parler à un tiers nous amenons des
parlementaires européens de tous
horizons des portugais de canaris de
madère et c'est pour pouvoir nous
retrouver et essayer d'apporter notre
pierre
vous avez vu qu est-ce qui est à la tête
de collecter de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique alfred marie
jeanne et claude lise se sont pas des
petits jeunots vous avez vu qu'ils sont
à la tête des communautés
d'agglomération se sont pas des petits
jeunots vous croyez qu'ils n'ont pas
encore compris
cette notion de relais concernant la les
affaires européennes
je ne dirais pas qu'ils n'ont pas
compris en tout cas ce n'est pas si
apparent parce que on ne voit pas
justement à quoi cela aboutit donc la
question son envie de leur dire ce matin
six autres packs à comprendre
s'acquitter ça non je ne suis pas dans
cette je ne vais pas rentrer encore là
dessus ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le constat est là les
relais sont insuffisants l'outre-mer est
négligée c'est la raison pour laquelle
je dis le modem sur le plan national
décide de porter sur la scène nationale
la question économique la politique
économique de l'outre-mer sur la
question européenne est bien plutôt que
de faire appel à un lobbying x y ou z et
bien amenons une formation européenne
d'envergure ici avec des personnalités
reconnues pour qu'il touche du doigt nos
réalités et que nous puissions avoir
effectivement une fluidité dans les
échanges il nous reste trente 30
secondes
max orville est ce que vous entendrez la
main aux responsables locaux dans marche
pour créer une nouvelle dynamique plus
efficace et être des relais du parti
présidentiel y siens en martinique à
fort-de-france
écoutez je ne
ni moi ni le modem nous n'avons
d'animosité envers est-ce que vous avez
tendu la main
est ce que vous avez en marche mais nous
avions travaillé avec en marche pendant
la culotte de l'action présidentielle
mais est depuis la nomination de sept
référente la dame d'acier
nous ne nous sommes pas va dire
rencontre est pour l'instant assez de
relais m non mais ça vient vous savez
chaque chose en son temps
en revanche si vous me posez la question
de savoir si nous rencontrons bon nombre
de marcheurs et d'élus qui se
revendiquait dans marche
et bien c'est le cas merci max orville
président du modem merci d'abriter dans
ce crédit merci
[Musique]